everything hurts I don't know why but my
teeth and my ballsack hurt I even
touched myself couldn't if I want to my
penis has no energy
Oh what is going on YouTube [ __ ] [ __ ]
so this has been the first week on my
body and my lifestyle transformation
goal and this has been the worst week of
my life if you guys don't know the first
week back in the gym is by far the worst
and you want to know why it's because
your body is not used to this type of
unwanted abuse that's right I said a
belt this whole time you were just
chilling with your stomach and your ass
and your bicep Alice and you try secular
Cloris that's a scientific name and you
thought what
and your man processes was cool chilling
just flopping about that suddenly BAM
you decided to suddenly go and put your
body into work blindsided unfairly
treating your body like that shit's been
so good to you eat until the home listen
my titties are so sore right now you
have no idea how can I explain this to
you it feels like I went to prison and I
got titty [ __ ] by dude named twinkle
nuts and here's a rule of thumb if
you're a prison and you have a [ __ ] ass
name most likely you're the most
dangerous person in the pan what's your
name [ __ ] twinkle nut mother [ __ ] uh
I'm [ __ ] with that [ __ ] got a lisp
he's crazy
mmm listen I already learned from Mike
Tyson if you buff and you got a lisp
something just might give it off look at
your dick here's the thing I think the
biggest struggle right now is getting
into the gym because when your sword you
don't want to do [ __ ] and you guys ever
noticed how when your sword you can make
up about 3,000 excuses not to go work
out in about two seconds because
sometimes it could be the most important
[ __ ] but when your sword you still want
to do it hey dumb your cars getting
broken into [ __ ] I got insurance I'm
sore how the holy man Jesus will get his
ass with a thunderbolt tomorrow I'm good
I pray I hate it when people tell me
that if I just get my fat ass up and
actually get into the gym then I will be
motivated to do [ __ ] you don't know me
at all do you
look here ask for a face I will walk
into a gym lay on a bench with two
dumbbells on my chest and knock out like
this personally I don't have that
internally competitive drive to not look
weak next to someone else I'm used to
that [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll curl up ten pound
dumbbell in front of a mirror like a
boss
to my knowledge store this happens
because when you're working on the waite
training you turn down your muscles and
you're building them back up stronger
right let me tell you something I am NOT
Wolverine because that healing process
needs to start up a lot faster listen I
hate being sore I don't care what people
say I just want to take a [ __ ] without
questioning if I'm a passed-out or not
look I gotta be honest with you I hate
feeling like this dude like I hate
feeling like a piece of [ __ ] and when
you're tired your body's aching your
sword this is where it becomes the
hardest to remember what you're even
doing this in the first place and I'll
be honest with you guys every morning
that I wake up and I feel like this I I
want to quit I just want to [ __ ] quit
but doing these videos is a reminder
that I should be doing this and it kind
of keeps my eye on the prize and kind of
keeps us all accountable and I hope you
guys are doing this video with me too
because if not then I don't I don't know
man I think this is a good opportunity
for all of us look I never told you guys
this was gonna be easy I told you from
the get-go this was gonna be [ __ ]
hard and I'm not always here to flock to
you guys about positive she don't always
say you know what the soreness feels
good because it doesn't effort those of
you out there they say I love it when
I'm sword shut the [ __ ] up you I've
never really been sore then why don't
you try working out with bar Quan and
tell me if you like being sore it feels
like I got [ __ ] by cactus Fitness fam
remember life is always what you make it
but it's up to you to take what you
deserve let's go for broke hey what is
going on YouTube now haha yes the first
week of this whole Fitness expediter
is that the word exponential has now
passed I am absolutely miserable and in
about a couple hours I'm going to go
work out again and I hate it but
remember every Wednesday I will be
posting up another fitness vlog and it
turns if you guys want to hear about how
much weight I've lost already I'm not
going to let you guys know that until
way later it's not important numbers
aren't important about how you feel and
the other problems are that's coming
along in terms of strength and stuff
like that so but as always once again
[ __ ] your tees that go-for-broke apparel
calm this is the plumeria tee which is
one of my personal favorites I don't
know still I like it you like it you
like it you like it
hey but remember keep your eye on the
prize and the gold on the bowl
I'm just writing [ __ ] right now I'm so
sorry ah so this is my first day waking
up after I just worked out last night
[ __ ] man I'm oh my god I'm miserable oh
there there are parts of your body that
workout you don't even need man I ain't
even do ab just a my my stomach this or
what the [ __ ] oh but this is this is
what it is man
like I'm telling you guys right now for
all you guys are overweight mmm and you
feel like you can't do it just because
it's hard tell you something
nobody [ __ ] said it was gonna be easy
man and a lot of things are side that
you want you're gonna have to work for
it's gonna be difficult and um so I'm
doing it right now man I'm trying to
show you guys like what it takes you
know I've lost a lot of weight before in
my past I was like 285 pounds and then I
dropped down to 220 and I did that
through a lot of hard work and I'm doing
it again cuz I cuz I need this I don't
know this is gonna be hard to work
through this this wall is hard to break
through and you know I'm I'm all full of
jokes of [ __ ] but I honestly feel like I
got [ __ ] by a gorilla that's yeah um
this is just the beginning the [ __ ] I
look like man